what up space fam golson here from anime
upper and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest and craziest spoilers
in the one piece series we find out the
crazy reason that buggy became a yonko
and wow it is amazing we see what
happens to the straw hats and others
post wano and we finally see whether or
not yamato officially joins the straw
hat crew and whether or not luffy
already has the 10 people he set out to
get in chapter 1. so make sure to stay
tuned for these game-changing spoilers
and for fun i decided to do an instagram
poll again on the anime uproar instagram
story about whether you think buggy's
bounty is higher or luffy's i'll reveal
the outcome on my full review video
later in the week so feel free to leave
your vote like last time when 91 percent
of people thought shanks would beat
sakazuki in a fight if you do enjoy
these one-piece spoiler videos and want
to keep them coming chill parking with
it and smash that like button be a
smashing power king rather than passing
orochi and youtube will reward you with
fireworks celebrating your awesomeness
if you haven't make this the video you
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications or you will
miss future one-piece videos and updates
including the full review later in the
week finally while you wait for the next
video to drop feel free to check out my
growing one piece playlist that includes
videos on all the yonko warlords
admirals mythical zones and much more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado let's jump into it
spoilers and all so this chapter is
called cross guild and it's a reference
to buggy's new organization in the news
back when buggy heard the news of
doflamingo's downfall he celebrated
because his organization buggy's
delivery had a boom in business he
offered people pirate mercenaries and
even proclaimed they had a monopoly on
the fighting business at this point he
was a warlord and so every act of piracy
under the name of buggy the genius
chester became the legal business of a
warlord yes there were hiccups like his
biggest breadwinners leaving at one
point but all in all it was a great
system unfortunately it didn't last long
since the world government
understandably decided to abolish the
warlord system buggy himself was
confronted by marines led by vice
admiral stainless he was planning to
motivate his men to fight and in the
chaos he was planning to slip away we
also saw the marines approaching other
warlords like mihawk those poor fools
that's where we left buggy and then
somehow just recently we received news
that he somehow managed to turn the
seemingly hopeless situation around and
not only that he became one of the yonko
as well so we still don't know exactly
how he got out of this exact situation
with stainless but we do know how he
became a yonko and wow it's brilliant
buggy's new organization we're told has
crocodile and mihawk as members yes it's
true just like so many people including
me were really hoping for like i said a
lot of us expected this to be the case
because of how awesome it would be and
it actually came to fruition and i'm so
hyped about it this is amazing and means
that buggy's crew now has the greatest
swordsman in the world outclassing
luffy's in at least that department for
now at least although i feel like soon
i'll have to do a poll on whether zorro
or mihawk would win in a fight now since
i love hearing your opinions and zorro
does keep getting stronger now in
reality mihawk probably joined because
it was a convenient partnership but it's
still awesome that now buggy at least
from the outside looking in looks like
he has mihawk and crocodile working
under him i can't wait to hear their
official reasons for joining leave your
thoughts in the comments below all i
know is that buggy is a genius and he
really made lemonade from lemons here he
turned a situation where the government
turned on him and used it as an
opportunity to make a kind of warlord
alliance absolutely brilliant and it
makes so much sense that the warlords
would do this since they were a great
force together government approval or
not the government really messed up when
they turned against buggy and i love to
see it also can't wait to see who else
buggy may have recruited in the meantime
another brilliant and unbelievably hyped
detail is that buggy put bounties on the
heads of the marines can you believe
that what a genius move that i didn't
expect to happen we always took it for
granted that having marine bounties
would be cool but it's not gonna happen
since they are issued by the marines but
now we have pirates unifying and
fighting back giving them bounties for a
change and i absolutely love it it's
brilliant i can't overemphasize how much
i love this idea you can see why this
counter system targeting marines alone
through their own bounties would make
buggy's organization so dangerous buggy
was already like my top 5 characters and
he really earned that position here we
are told though that no bounties are
revealed in this chapter although i
can't wait to compare pirate bounties to
marine bounties and see how they stack
up like what'll sakazuki's be compared
to shanks oda really is the hype
building master the chapter then goes on
we're told that neko and inu are staying
in wano probably to help momo guard it
and they have chosen carrot as their
successor to lead the mix so although
carrot will make a great ally it's clear
she is enjoying the straw hats as many
wish to see i know all of you guys care
a lot about this next one but shinobu is
beautiful again thanks to aramaki's
attack we're told and by the way i was
kidding i know this is not the most
interesting news to anybody but hey i am
never one to complain about more
attractive women in one piece and i know
this middle stuff wasn't the most
interesting per se but trust me the
chapter finishes strong with relevancy
so just be patient we're told luffy kid
and law set off on different routes not
something i'm surprised by or
disappointed about although i definitely
think we haven't seen the last of a law
and luffy alliance kid is looking for
someone but it's not shanks we're told
and that makes sense we all know he'd be
able to accomplish nothing against the
shanks from last chapter wow i still
can't get over how epic shanks was then
we're told we see yamato standing on the
castle roof why is this significant
because i just told you the straw hats
left and although many thought yamato
would join including yamato and even i
thought it would be great i also kept
saying it's hard to believe since yamato
has the guardian deity of wano fruit
that belongs in wano of course plus they
kept not showing luffy officially
letting her join and there was that
moment with momo i pointed out in the
last chapter which hinted yamato would
stay we're told to be careful and the
yamato situation is unclear at the
moment and that no reliable spoiler
providers explain what exactly happened
so we'll have to wait and see before
coming to a definitive conclusion i mean
it's possible that yamato could join
them later but as i've been pointing out
there has been so much foreshadowing
that yamato would stay that i can't say
i'd be surprised if yamato didn't join
the crew at this point like for example
imagine if chaka the jackal whose fruit
is considered to be the guardian deity
of alabasta joined the crew and left to
do his own thing it would never happen
and now that we know that zone fruits
have wills of their own and they must
have some sway on their users after all
chopper's personality is probably more
human zone fruit than reindeer at this
point then it's likely that yamato will
be influenced to stay or that the fruit
picked yamato because it knew yamato
would stay when the time came don't get
me wrong though i'm open-minded and
would love to see yamato join so let's
just wait and see what happens smash
that like button if you enjoyed this
spoiler video and want to keep them
coming be a smashing power king rather
than passing orochi and youtube will
reward you with fireworks celebrating
your epic awesomeness if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell to turn on all notifications or you
will miss future one-piece videos and
updates including the full review later
in the week remember that you can vote
in the poll on the anime uproar
instagram about who has the higher
bounty luffy or buggy and then i'll show
the results on the full chapter review
so don't miss that either drop a hashtag
all hail buggy in the comments if you're
a real one and made it all the way to
the end thank you i really appreciate it
finally while you wait for the next
video to drop feel free to check out my
growing one piece playlist that includes
videos on all the yonko warlords
admirals mythical zones and much more
link to that is in the description and
on screen right now and until next time
see ya space cowboys now let me end this
off with the long bang to make sure this
video gets over 8 minutes bang
baby